that's the song for Shenmue you Shenmue
fans should know and love there's a
third Shenmue coming yu Suzuki can put a
good man down
Peter brands here Kevin van org for your
own ultimate lobby appearance ultimate
is ultimate it is a whole last oh my
good it is my last lock technically this
will be a break end will be split into
two maybe you'll have me back
but don't worry about maybe as writer of
a video game you know we'll talk about
that sure but first of all I wanna talk
to you about Shenmue Shenmue 3
kick-started 6.2 million dollars making
it the highest supported Kickstarter in
the video game space it's in the top
five I think otherwise sixty nine
thousand people decided to throw money
at this I was one of them but I don't
know why I got caught up in the moment I
did - you did - because you want to know
why yeah cuz I wanted the physical ps4
version and they're not guaranteeing
it's going to come out outside of the
Kickstarter in a physical way / well
it's only 60 bucks oh god I Boni give
them 25 I guess I'm getting the PC
version yeah I'd never played a Shenmue
I think I might have played like 50
minutes in like a video game store when
a Dreamcast it was just hooked up there
you did back in the day and Kevin you
have I have recently weeks
yeah wait to talk to you guys about this
Peter what was your experience what do
you remember your experience play
Shenmue was back in whatever 99 or 2000
yeah so I did play a little bit recently
but going back you know it was it was a
game that was so much especially on
consoles so much more open and it gave
you the time to explore things and you
know walk around this town that felt
like a little town but of course it
wasn't really that great of an
experience it wasn't necessarily
believable everything was there like the
making of a little town but everyone you
spoke to it seemed like everyone was
playing a trick on you were they all
said the same thing and like no one had
their own personality and it was just a
really kind of like awkward game in a
lot of ways did you feel free yeah right
what you wanted
free is this even a term people use
anymore
what did it stand for again free
reactive I entertainment maybe something
like that it was basically the idea of
making a like what we would consider an
open world right like in a world where
you are free to do things which don't
necessarily impact on the story but with
a convoluted Japanese acronym right yes
exactly
what is the sort of moment to moment
play in this game cuz yeah I know you
like you you obviously have to like have
your job and you're also like trying to
find a because I quest and you're like
talking to people lots of conversations
lots of QuickTime events what were you
doing moments a moment is Shenmue Peter
so you're doing a lot of investigating
so you go around you talk to people who
hopefully have information that will
help you find the person who murdered
your father right a hope in that
sentence there yeah everyone you talk to
knows you so you constantly hear oh
hello yo so ever yeah see I'm sorry
and the voice acting is is so painfully
bad and it like I really appreciate what
that game tried what uses you he tried
to do with that game and granted he was
doing it at a time booked so yeah you
can play our kid games in Shenmue so
yeah the stuff he was doing at the time
it was like commendable then he went to
those lengths and obviously he's going
to stumble when this is something he has
no basis for record a reference you know
for but you Suzuki as well was
originally an arcade developer mhm as
well so going back to his roots there
yeah oh yeah you were saying like it was
a sort of it was almost like breaking
new ground like the open world world was
a whole new thing so a lot of people say
that they didn't use the voice acting
that they used this sort of Japanese
stuff and how to translate it did you
have any experience of doing that or has
subtitled rather no I never had a chance
to play it that way on their films it
the new ones have been translated to a
bunch of different languages as well but
first of all before we talk about that
Kickstarter Ken viroid you went back and
played like two weeks ago I did I did I
Shenmue is on that list of like games of
shame or now like that list of games
that you feel like you should have
played and never did yes so I started
playing it and it's quite an experience
I'll tell you I think the thing oh my
god how did you dug this up they went to
my twitch channel insist all my content
I did not approve of it still oh your
own your content until Friday oh my god
you're so right about that
in fact we owned this because you did it
when you were on our employee so here
also those pads oh right so here's so
here's me sitting in my home playing
Shenmue thanks guys how are you playing
this first of all I was playing that
this I'm playing on emulator okay so
this was this that yeah yeah yeah yeah
well will not talk too much about that
but this is this this I'm playing on
emulator and what's what's really and
what was really interesting to stick to
stick out I mean from the very beginning
from the very opening you know cutscene
and I'm coming this with eyes from now
right I didn't play this in the day I
don't have the nostalgia built around it
and so I'm coming from you know from the
point of view of somebody in the future
from this game and so much was so
painful I'm just the opening cutscene
it's weird because it means to be
dramatic and I've never played a game
that wants to be dramatic like this and
yet is so utterly devoid of an actual
drama like it's just weird how they add
it like the even the opening cutscene
one of the the most confusing things
when I even started there's a couple
things that I think are really funny go
for it one is the opening scene it's it
snows and it rains okay in the opening
cutscene or maybe Peter can shed some
light on us this is I don't understand
why it snows and then it rains okay and
then later on when you talk to people
they talk about some people say oh the
night that it rained and everyone's like
oh yeah snowed that night and it's like
did it do both did they change it from
snow to rain
so here it's snowing look at snowing but
then it and then it lightnings and it
rains at some other point it was very
confusing and then when you talk to
Grandma at some point she's like I'm you
know I have to keep busy because
otherwise I just get depressed and I
love ríos response which which is basis
like oh that's just like you grandma
always the right way is depressed that's
good old grandma for you back on your
man he just wants to kill herself no
biggie
so it is there certain amount of like
maybe lost in translation happening here
oh for sure because the English the the
English translation and the voice acting
are just awful I think even by any
standard and yet it's funny because I
want to keep going yeah I kind of want
to see what
happens next even though I feel like I'm
going up to just a bunch of weird people
for sailors look I'm still looking for
people that are you know I'm still
finding people saying did you see men in
black driving a black car but then there
are these special moments it's like you
go around and one of the first scenes
that you you deal with like when you go
out into town is there's this girl with
a little box of kittens that you talk to
and then later on if you talk to her
again you get the chance to name the
kittens from like one of five different
choices and then the dialogue reacts to
that you actually call the kitten by
name and that kind of stuff and that
kind of thing was like basically just
didn't happen in video games at that
point you know it's funny because it
wasn't that many years before then Grand
Theft Auto 3 existed yeah kind of
changed this whole idea of open world
cities forever but but you know on one
hand I admire it on the other hand I
think it's ridiculous and and not good
but there's the kitty it's so cute I'm
just gonna say Kevin you've thrown down
the gauntlet on this this video games
right there was one kitten really the
only thing you can do now is go write
your own video game because it's not
fair for you to sit here on your critics
high horse I know and talk about you get
out there and fix it yourself fix the
problem the source I know I'm a
hypocrite are you gonna keep playing it
I think so I'm kind of curious if only
it's wrong right I never finished long
all right
but this is it's interesting because the
face fortunate its article turn your
head the other way man
and you can't it's a OGG I feel like
this is one of those games where your
mind fills in the blank you can only do
like a lot of people overlook the dumb
stuff because they see what this game
could be like the game that this is in
their mind is so incredible that it's
sort of hard to escape that and that's
what sticks with us it's like I know if
I can play GTA 3 like the version in
your heads when you actually play a
friend no this is like right so limits
yeah but that's I think what we want
from a Shenmue 3 it right is is
something that is like that game we made
the original Shenmue and
heads yes and hope that it will be that
of course I have kind of I think the
whole Kickstarter thing on you know and
it being also financed by Sony and that
kind of thing I think that's all that's
all this weird Kickstarter thing that I
feel very funny about the idea of
gauging audience interest by creating a
Kickstarter also getting no money from
write this this game right so they're
basically just sort of facilitating some
of them and they might get some sort of
time dick which is go see if it perhaps
because they haven't talked about an
Xbox version right so but I wonder what
what it what is a game like this gonna
be even with this funding we talked
about like oh you know all these
millions of dollars sounds like a lot
for a game like what we think we want
from Shenmue 3 this is a paltry amount
of money for what I think people are
really gonna want from Shenmue 3 and so
I'm really curious to see where this
goes and again I always I'm always a
little weirded out by the idea of
Kickstarter's that are used to gauge
audience interest anyway rather than as
actual funding mechanisms for for games
of a very good for a game otherwise yeah
and and so I don't know mixed feelings
there for me but yeah 6.5 million
dollars or was it 6.3 which is nothing
no which is no money yeah even in terms
of Shenmue games cuz the original was
what 55 or 60 million yeah but the
problem there is that they originally
developed it for the Sega Saturn and
they actually got pretty far into
development before they had to scrap it
and start over
oh really oh yeah it's a sorry I'm sorry
yeah so they did we've got it here up on
the screen as some of the stretch goals
that got hit Shenmue 1 and 2 cinema
shorts and we also have it in Italian
Dutch French Spanish and Portuguese so
all of Europe they're getting terrible
voice acting perhaps and a rapport
system I love when they do it by system
it's the weirdest way of thinking about
game design right it's like oh we got
enough money we're gonna put in the
skill tree system and the rapport system
and various mini extend their semi goals
was like 500k on top of whatever the
last one was for improved ragdoll
physics yeah it's like you need $500,000
to have the characters flop around a
little bit the residence is that what
you want the 500 hours we go no no
they've also expanded various villages
and battle systems you know putting more
development time into certain little
towns and whatnot you can go to yeah
coming to PC and ps4 sometime in 2017
this thing I don't believe it
are you like you know you don't believe
it you don't believe we'll see if by
2017 no but I'm looking forward to this
game I don't I don't have high hopes for
it but I like that it exists and I like
that it's so odd and that there is this
ambition behind it and even if it's not
going to be realized perfectly the way
it was imagined it's just fun to see
people experiment and try it kind of
wacky things that you didn't think would
exist right I mean we've been joking
about this game coming for years and
here it is and I'm not convinced anymore
than I was four years ago if I would
have told you no they're not gonna make
it because no one really would no one
really wants to play this game I have a
reaiiy of a question is the screen
tearing in are is is that just something
that's on the monitor that I'm looking
at I'm just curious like a giant screen
tear in the game if they hit anyway
sorry and then we're gonna get rid of
screen tearing oh man I'd looked I just
take the rag doll to go to like a
consistent where everything is so you
should just be able to kick around dead
bodies right then if we know anything
gonna make Gears of War yeah that's how
it works
I love kick it's worth a lot ease
especially in Japan and sometimes even
in games yes yeah
nice one that's why we keep you on board
yeah I'm known for my my funny yes but
that dick joke that was on before we
went alive as well that was I made a
dick joke yeah what did I do that you
could do another one in a second oh I'm
Han all right stay tuned for more dick
jokes Peter Brown Kevin alright thank
you very much for talking about Shenmue